it's hard to tell but the man behind
that white bushy beard is Harrison Ford
I'm all grown up now
the 73 year old looked barely
recognizable while Tory Spain with wife
Calista Flockhart the couple took in the
sights arm-in-arm on Wednesday Calista
rocked a classy polkadot dress and navy
cardigan while Harrison opted to go for
more average Joe with a great t-shirt
Olive trousers and black and yellow
sneakers who said Indiana Jones can't
pulled off casual I feel pretty good it
wasn't the only rare appearance from the
Hollywood a-listers on Friday they were
snapped in Alhambra later that evening
the Super Girl actress slipped into a
fancier outfit for a shopping trip with
her hubby the two held hands while
strolling the streets of Barcelona but
can we talk about Harrison's bushy beard
looks like the actor is enjoying the
facial hair while he can before he
donned the hat and whip again as Indiana
Jones the fifth film in the beloved
franchise is set to hit theaters July
2019